president peter metallica wasn't
impressed in February when malawi
judiciary overturned his victory in the
last election judges ruled it was marked
by widespread penetrating so Malawians
voted again in a rerun
despite the corona virus pandemic many
voters weren't wearing masks or ensuring
social distancing voting was generally
peaceful except with some violence in
opposition strongholds in central malawi
[Music]
the main opposition leader lazarus
chacarera
says he is confident this time all
election officials will act
professionally to ensure credibility he
appeals to all Minoans to remain
peaceful
there is no reason really to resort to
violence this is a peaceful country and
we all need to vote peacefully and we
all need to respect one another and we
do not need to fight they vote itself is
the fight we need the winner needs to
secure more than 50% of the vote
president metallica has so far refused
to sign a proposed law providing for a
runoff election in 30 days if needed
some analysts warn that could create
problems therefore you would think that
the most straightforward route would be
simply for the president to assent to
that bill because if he did then we
wouldn't even be standing here asking
that question because there would be a
statutory framework which says if it
doesn't happen then you wait for so many
days and then you have an election which
involves a
contest between the two top candidates
whether there is an outright winner or a
runoff many analysts say essentially the
selection is a two horse race between
Metallica who has been praised for
revamping Malawi's infrastructure but
criticized for failing to tackle
corruption and Shakira who is promising
to fight corruption and create jobs the
election result is expected within eight
days her Matassa al-jazeera